do you have a problem do you have a
problem asking people progress no if you
if you were here right now if you came
over you'd see i have a room full of uh
posters autographed horror movies i got
the whole cast signed aliens my thing by
kurt russell signed the thing poster and
escape from new york uh my fright night
poster from the director tom holland
evil dead bruce campbell
kiefer sutherland and jason patrick
signed my lost boys poster uh i just i
don't give a [ __ ] man i just i love it i
was a collector i
went to cons conventions before i was an
actor or made it or anything and i just
still feel like that kid so yeah i don't
give a [ __ ]
but i know most people do most people
are like i don't ask for autographs
that's weird dude
yeah i don't know i i i i don't have
i mean i'm trying to think if i have
autographs i i not that i i think i have
a few jerseys down stairs
filming people
you have joe montana i i have a football
from him i did ask him for see this is
the thing people will [ __ ] it up for you
right i i was at a um
i think it was a madden event you know
when when when they used to like ask
celebrities to come out we were doing
like a
flag football game for madden yeah and
it was down and and um
i got uh
i got montana's autograph and i asked
for another guy's
um not gonna name his name but he gave
me the dirtiest [ __ ] look when i got
it
and i was like man i don't i didn't want
to do this to begin with and now you're
giving me making me feel bad wow
[ __ ] i miss i didn't i mean i can't do
it
i don't think
i don't think i've done it since i mean
oh man i did that with uh mike tyson
mike tyson was on the show called
breaking and he was just a guest star
and i had some scenes with him and i go
and i i said [ __ ] for the cast i bought
a whole bunch of boxing gloves like six
of them or seven of them and i go i came
in this trailer i go hey would you sign
i go beforehand i go would you mind
signing a glove he goes no absolutely
man you know signing your glove i'll
sign the boxing glove for you and i went
into his uh trailer and i had he goes
what the what the [ __ ] is this man
i go oh it's just for the cast he goes
oh [ __ ] man i just thought i thought i
was signing for just you man i go oh oh
you can my bad i just thought he goes no
that's fine man that's fine but i could
tell he was upset and i was like [ __ ]
dude and then i thought he gives a [ __ ]
i'll never see him again [ __ ] it i just
got six no no you know
he's probably thinking back look dude i
give you a [ __ ] i give you a morsel
and you ask for the whole your eyes yeah
by the way that's his whole life right
he's right though he's right i was a
dick you're right i just thought about
it i'm a dick
but i still but you're you're welcome
cast i'm appreciative of [ __ ]
uh he was
he was on on on franklin and bash as
well
and um
uh brecken
had a funny little face to face with him
uh he was he it was right after he did
this um you know the whole thing with
the with the broadway thing
yeah and it was like everybody was so
impressed with how he did and so that's
what he was supposed to play like this
refined
man who gave up violence
and um
the line
like
long story short brecken's supposed to
hit him and he's supposed to be like why
would you do that
you know i'm i'm i'm just
you know i'm a broadway guy now kind of
thing but he took it the other way no
one gave him any direction so when
brecken does his fake punch to and and
you know hits him he gets in brecken's
face as full
mike tyson like the guy that you fear
he's like why the [ __ ] would you do that
like all of us
back the [ __ ] up and i was like whoa
this guy is going to attack brecken
and then after that take was over the
director's like that was great mike uh
we're gonna go in a different direction
we're going to we're going to you know
it's actually the opposite of that
you're just you're you're you're the guy
on broadway you know that that guy
that's the guy we want he's like oh okay
okay okay yeah i got that wrong and he
did it it was great but man he's he's
he's still so freaking intense oh my god